i know you guys want some comedy and i
got some for you
i got some for you don't worry
[Music]
extra extra arena thank you dm extra
extra
boy have we got an extra ordinary mr zed
show this time
i ought to know i'm mr zed but enough of
this
rambling on let's check out the news in
the mr zedd show check it out
that'll be 35 cents please
yeah mr zev is an mc all right
mental case get it
you you don't get it you don't
understand
i wish you'd pay a little attention
splooty i'm already paying as little
attention as i can
what has four legs but only one
foot i don't know a bed
huh huh
a bed
a guy's a bed think about it the foot of
the bed
you don't get it so a bed is held up by
four like feet right but then you say
the
foot of the bed would be like the end of
the bed
i'll explain the jokes to you these are
a little high bro i got you there don't
worry about it
uh uh could adam and eve ever have a
date
no they had an apple
first off they had fruit from the tree
of knowledge nobody ever [ __ ] said it
was an apple alright
nobody ever said it was an apple
nobody ever said
that it was an apple
let's check out how things are going
down at the genetics lab hey doctor
how's it going
great mr zed i couldn't do finer
just this morning we successfully
crossed an electric
eel and a jellyfish what did you get
current jelly
shotgun great great oh it's fantastic
today i'm at what the british call a
petrol pump what the americans call
a gas pump this isn't a gas pump
this is a liquid pump liquid comes out
of here
fuel for your car but the point is
another one too
you see gasoline as a fuel is really an
explosive
we know this is this isn't a children's
show by the way
i just want to point that out i know you
will maybe it's a kitchen it's not a
kids show
right little bitty drops of gasoline
into the pistons in your car
push up the piston rods they do it so
fast it goes
in fact when you play cars and you go
[Applause]
what you're really doing is imitating
those thousands and thousands of little
explosions
but remember and this is important
petrol is not a gas
gas gas it's not a gas it's a liquid
and that's the way i see it
who gets the sack every time he goes to
work
i don't know the postman
he's really funny
would you like to buy a henway what's a
henway
how about four or five pounds
because
it's much a chicken wings
what is it that gets wetter the more it
dries
i don't know a towel
so he's just doing these [ __ ] hack
generic jokes that everybody knows
when is a green book not a green book
i don't know when it's red
red no i get it no i got it i get it i'm
sorry i can't even go with a bit anymore
i got it bud
i'm so glad the show is gonna have a
happy ending today
yeah everybody will be glad when it's
over
[Music]
oh hi well that's this week's show
i hope you enjoyed it and i hope you'll
be with us next time when we have an
all news show see you then
aloha
did that help you guys
huh
whoa look at that
now after thinking about it i think i
have found a new gimmick
thank you royce december will be
oh come on
[ __ ] you frozen
we're beginning to plan a covet
christmas
now it's lock down number two
if you're ordering turkey for ten you
might want to think again
it might be best to use deliveroo
delivery deliveroo you you had time to
pre-write this song
and deliver you're beginning to plan a
cold at christmas
that means no nativity
well it wouldn't be quite the same
seeing wise men by the manger wearing
pp
a drink in a pub or a friend that can
hug is the wish of sarah and ben
a job a career no lockdown next year is
the hope of harry and jen
and will we ever get to see our families
[Music]
buying all our gifts online
you can still pop your cards in the post
just don't lick the envelope
we're hoping that they all arrive on
time
we're beginning to plan a cold christmas
look i want a new christmas song as much
as anybody but i just why why this one
[Music]
and we'll still decorate a tree i will
not apologize making fun of your [ __ ]
stupid hats
[Music]
as a matter of fact frozen
i'm just gonna take your gimmick from
you i'm gonna take it
i'm gonna take your gimmick i'm gonna
just start wearing stupid hats
and ruining people's days i mean i
already ruined people's days
so [ __ ] i start wearing stupid hats like
you what do you think it's the virus
why do i feel like listening to free
form jazz all of a sudden
[Music]
we're beginning to plan a covet
[Music]
and if the government carries on then
2021
will be
it's [ __ ]
i mean look honestly i've heard worse
pretty so i've heard worse
worse parody songs um you know the funny
thing about this hat i was thinking
about the cats like this is that
check this out you word forward right
white guy doing white guy things all of
a sudden
black guy from the 90s now i'm a black
guy the sam jackson
all right [ __ ] fix hold on there we
go black guy
from the 90s look see look what do you
think it is
yo what's up man i'm gonna spit some
knowledge to you it really all depends
on how you wear it
it really does oh the front front look
is a little bit better in my opinion
i don't like a british cabbie
not the person but like someone that
drives a cab not cabbie the cabbie
um
fine another okay another try for
christmas song janie terry
where's my
[Music]
naughty no more
look this isn't gonna cut it we're
really looking for a new christmas song
maybe one day we'll find it today's
obviously not gonna be that day but i
promise you i'm gonna keep looking okay
i'm gonna get we obviously know it can't
be the cheeky girls because that'll
[ __ ] you're not allowed to have a
cheeky christmas
but i promise you i'm gonna keep looking
and we will eventually find it we will
eventually find it